[Musik]
da sind wir guten Tag und herzlich
willkommen zum Presseclub live aus Köln
wir haben einen ganz wunderbaren Sonntag
gerade schön warm schöner Spätsommertag
so wie wir es eigentlich genießen wollen
und trotzdem ist es ja so dass viele von
uns auch die Bilder aus den vergangenen
Wochen und Tagen im Kopf haben von den
Unwettern im Ausland wir schauen mal
drauf was passiert ist Hongkong zum
Beispiel kämpft mit den schlimmsten
Regenfällen seit 140 Jahren Griechenland
erlebte nie da gewesene
Niederschlagsmengen auch Teile
Brasiliens der Türkei und Bulgarien sind
überflutet das sind Wassermassen die
alles zerstören Infrastruktur jeden
privaten sitzt maximale Verwüstung sehen
wir da und wirklich Milliardenschäden
dann ein Hurrikan der Richtung Florida
unterwegs ist aktuell Kanada haben wir
erlebt mit brennenden die kaum unter
Kontrolle zu bringen waren und wir
müssen auch nach Afrika schauen an das
Horn von Afrika dort leiden die Menschen
unter der größten Dürre seit 40 Jahren
wir haben global gesehen jetzt den
heißesten Sommer seit Beginn der
Aufzeichnungen erlebt und unser Thema
heute im Presseclub ist Sommer der
extreme wo bleibt die globale Antwort
auf die Klimakrise da muss er auch schon
mal dazu sagen die Fakten sind da wir
haben Wissenschaftler die vieles belegen
und trotzdem fragt man sich für uns alle
auch wo bleibt der Rock wo bleibt die
große Aufforderung der große Schwung zu
sagen wir müssen das jetzt angehen
darüber wollen wir diskutieren ich freue
mich auf meine Gäste wir haben eine gute
Runde heute für Sie hier unter anderem
dabei herzlich willkommen Maren Urner
ist Neurowissenschaftlerin und
Publizistin herzlich willkommen auch
Jakob Schland Ressortleiter Tagesspiegel
background Energie und Klima außerdem
ist bei uns Carsten schwanke Meteorologe
und
Wissenschaftsjournalist und auch in
unserer Runde ist die Kollegin Julie
Journalistin und präsenterin für den WDR
Instagram Kanal
klimaneutral und natürlich wie immer
auch sie gerne hier herzlich willkommen
in unserer Hunde sie können mit
diskutieren ihre Fragen stellen zum
Thema auf den Social Media Kanälen das
Presse Clubs Karsten wir haben die
Bilder jetzt gerade gesehen die
Regenmengen haben große Hitze auch
erlebt in diesem Sommer wir ich schaue
global weltweit weil man möchte ja sagen
wieso wir hatten eigentlich nicht so
tollen Sommer hier in Deutschland sagt
der ein oder andere ist das was wieder
erleben was wir jetzt gesehen haben in
Bildern ist das Menschen gemacht der
Klimawandel in seinen Auswirkungen oder
ist das Wetter
wir haben doch vor 20 30 Jahren hätten
wir gesagt diese beiden Begriffe müssen
wir strengen wissenschaftlich
voneinander trennen Wetter ist das was
jetzt da draußen passiert was uns
emotional berührt und Klima sind
langjährige Mittelwerte wir müssen aber
sehen dass wir diesen Klimawandel nicht
dadurch spüren dass irgendwelche
statistischen Mittelwerte aus dem Wolken
herausfallen sondern wir werden diesen
Klimawandel über dass ich ändernde
Wetter erleben und genau das ist es und
seit den 1990er Jahren hat sich das was
wir als Wetter erleben komplett aus dem
natürlichen Rauschen aus der
Variabilität heraus bewegt also alles
was wir jetzt ein Wetter eigentlich
erleben das ist zurückzuführen in all
seinen schönen und auch dramatischen und
gefährlichen Auswirkungen ist
zurückzuführen auf diesen erhöhten CO2
Ausstoß und wenn man nur mal das Jahr
2023 nehmen müssen du hast ja gerade
gesagt es ist das wärmste ja das
weltweit bisher gemessen wurde es ist
aber nicht nur ein weiteres warmes ja
dass ich jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen an
die Spitze setzt ich kenne niemanden der
im letzten Jahr dieses Jahr so hätte
vorher sein
wir sehen Rekorde auf allen Ebenen wir
haben noch nie da gewesene Ozean
Wassertemperaturen und auch das nicht
nur irgendwie ein bisschen mehr sondern
die aktuellen Messwerte springen
deutlich über alles was bisher bisher
gemessen wurde heraus die Monate Juli
und August die wurden ja weltweit waren
es die ersten beiden Monate die das 1,5
Grad Ziel sozusagen gerade gerissen
haben auch hier das 1,5 Grad Ziel da
reden wir von einem 30-Jährige
Mittelwert also es sind aber die ersten
Monate die 1,5 Grad wärmer waren als
normal und wir sehen ja die Folgen wir
haben zum ersten Mal in 2023 in allen
tropischen Meeresregionen
Hurricanes Taifun tropische Wirbelstürme
der höchsten Kategorie Kategorie 5 jetzt
schon gehabt und die Hurricane Saison
hat er gerade erst richtig angefangen
wir haben zum ersten Mal auf dem
Atlantik zwei große Hurricanes
gleichzeitig gehabt vor anderthalb
Wochen wir sehen Regenmengen also was
wegen Griechenland gesehen haben das
sind ja auch für dortige Regionen
komplett neue Dimensionen dort ist 7 mal
so viel Regen gefallen wie im Alter das
muss man sich einmal vorstellen und das
Tag für Tag neue Nachrichten ich sehe
gerade wie Frau ohne zuhört und zuschaut
sie beschäftigen sich auch mit dem was
bei uns im Kopf passiert gerade gemacht
hat weil er wirklich starke Zahlen
Bilder Eindrücke was macht das mit uns
sagen wir dann oh das ist mir zu heftig
da schalte ich ab oder ist es wichtig
dass wir solche Fakten auch immer wieder
rausholen
absolut und er hat im Prinzip im letzten
Satz genau den richtigen Begriff gesagt
nämlich vorstellen und wenn wir so ein
bisschen historisch noch mal gucken ist
eigentlich das was in der Klimakrise
erlebt haben bisher bzw wie wir es
vorher häufig genannt haben dem
Klimawandel was immer ein
vorstellungsproblem weil wenn wir noch
mal zurück gucken so vor 20 30 Jahren
oder selbst 2022 haben sich die Menschen
23 anders vorgestellt wir konnten uns
das im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes nicht
vorstellen und das war immer das Problem
dass auch medial dann natürlich
entsprechend abzubilden weil dann wurde
halt über das Wetter geredet und es
wurde irgendwie gesagt na ja da sind die
Eisbären und die stehen auf einer
Scholle und die schmilzt jetzt so ein
bisschen das ist von mir ganz weit weg
also von mir als Mensch ist das sozial
räumlich zeitlich überhaupt nicht
greifbar und jetzt haben wir so ein
bisschen und das ist die große Gefahr
und ich hoffe dass wir hier und heute
darüber sprechen können wir aus dieser
vorstellungskrise jetzt nicht in die
nächste vorstellungskrise kommen wo
Menschen sagen ja jetzt ist alles zu
spät ich kann mir nicht mehr vorstellen
wie wir Lösungen finden und wie wir
unsere Gesellschaft transformieren
müssen damit wir gut Zukunft auf diesem
gebeten haben aber es ist sehr schlank
eigentlich auch so dass man sagen müsste
okay wenn wir solche Bilder sehen wenn
wir Verwüstungen und Veränderungen
überhitzte Meere und so weiter wenn wir
darüber berichten müsste man dann
eigentlich auch jedes Mal nicht direkt
dazu sagen pass auf folgende
Auswirkungen sind dabei es geht um
Klimaflüchtlinge es geht aber zum
Beispiel auch um Nahrungsmittel
Knappheit um unseren Wohlstand müsste
man das eigentlich immer mit dazu sagen
oder ist es genau diese apokalyptische
Aussage wo alle sagen jetzt gehen wir
aber weg damit
man kann nicht immer jede Geschichte
komplett ausziehen wie Sie es gerade
angesprochen haben müssen sehr sehr
viele Dinge eben auch miteinander
verknüpft es gibt eine hängt natürlich
sehr von den politischen Systemen der
Stabilität eines Landes ab ob man eben
eine akute Krise auch in dem Moment
bewältigen kann das ist ja bei Hunger
Krisen auch sehr gut nachgewiesen wie
eng die mit politischer Stabilität
verknüpft sind ich würde gerne auf das
Thema Optimismus oder Pessimismus noch
mal zurückkommen ich glaube das muss man
nüchtern betrachten ja genau zeigt sich
jetzt eben die Erwärmung wir merken es
ganz privat ganz persönlich früher gab
es viele Sommer in denen es keine
einzige Tropennacht gab also wo kein
einziges Mal in Deutschland die
Temperatur nachts nicht unter 20 Grad
gefallen ist das kann man sich jetzt gar
nicht mehr vorstellen das ist aber noch
die harmlose Seite natürlich dieser
extremwetterzustände nehmen natürlich zu
mit der Feuchtigkeit in der Atmosphäre
der Klimawandel wird Fortschreiten die
Frage ist wird er katastrophal
vorbereiten und da haben wir jetzt auch
neue Zahlen darauf glaube ich würde ich
gerne noch zu sprechen kommen wir
steuern im Augenblick auf 2,4 bis 2,8
Grad Erwärmung zu das wäre katastrophal
unter zwei Grad ist noch zu schaffen 1,5
Grad nicht wir werden also noch eine
Verschlechterung erleben aber wir müssen
verhindern dass es katastrophal wird
irgendwann das Verständnis immer bei
Menschen aufhört ja 1,5 Grad was von 2,4
[Musik]
ein Grad mehr was Wasser was was wären
denn die Auswirkungen einfach dass wir
das auch in der vor müssen wir jetzt
wieder die Vorstellung bemühen weil das
ist ja noch nicht aber was was wäre eine
Auswirkung von einem Grad mehr
wenn du mal bei dem bleiben was wir
jetzt schon sehen diese Extremwetter die
wir jetzt in diesem Jahr vor allem
hatten die werden häufiger vorkommen die
werden noch stärker sein auch wir hier
in Deutschland werden sie häufiger haben
für uns bedeutet das vor allem in
unserem Breitengrad mehr Regen also es
wird feuchter oder wieder einige sagen
werden ja aber dann aber noch keine
Klimakrise nee das genau das Problem
dass wir diese Starkregen vermehrt haben
werden die wir auch im Juli hatten wo
dann auch schon wieder viele vergessen
hatten dass es Anfang Juli super heiß
war also drei Wochen reden dann reden
dann ist immer Hitze schnell Rasen schon
braun die Bilder haben wir damals alle
gesehen ja und ähm das bedeutet aber
ebenfalls allen bei uns eben mehr Regen
in anderen Teilen der Welt bedeutet dass
der Meeresspiegel steigt an das bedeutet
noch mehr Trockenheit ich war vor kurzem
in Honduras da habe ich das auch noch
mal sehr deutlich selber gesehen was das
für dieses kleine Land bedeutet dass der
Meeresspiegel dort ansteigt und Orte ja
Orte ins Meer zieht also die gehen
einfach verloren die Menschen können
nichts mehr anbauen die sind davon
abhängig also viele sind Selbstversorger
da vor Ort ist aber so trocken dass sie
eigentlich schon ja vorher sagen das
lohnt sich dieses Jahr nicht mehr und
auch dort vor Ort Stürme die dann
wirklich auch alles zerstören wo
Menschen alles verlieren die sowieso
schon super wenig haben und das ist zwar
räumlich weit weg aber wir müssen eben
auch an diese Menschen denken die es
nicht so gut haben wie wir wir haben
dann ja im besten Fall vom schlimmsten
Fall den Keller vollwasser aber die
Menschen verlieren eben alles kann ich
ganz kurz zu einem einhaken weil das
betrifft tatsächlich auch die Ernten
hier also der Deutsche Bauernverband hat
vor ich glaube zwei Wochen das ist ja
und ich habe selbst einen Text dann dazu
geschrieben hat gesagt dass wir in
Deutschland gerade eine Zitterpartie
erleben was sie Ernte hier betrifft also
um da vielleicht noch mal die
Hilfestellung absolut ich bin mal was
sie sagen natürlich dabei aber um auch
noch mal hier die Vorstellungskraft auf
den eigenen Teller zu projizieren bzw
sie da einfach auch vor Augen zu haben
wir haben auch hier genau diese Probleme
wir haben sie natürlich noch nicht jeden
Tag vor Augen und das was sie auch
gerade gesagt haben wir vergessen
schnell also neben dieser
vorstellungskrise die ich eben schon
kurz angesprochen habe haben wir eben
einfach so hier in unseren Köpfen das
ist auf kurzfristiges Denken optimiert
so und deshalb ein bisschen uns als
Gesellschaft in der zivilisatorischen
Gemeinschaft oder einem
zivilisatorischen Prozess ja fragen wenn
wir das verstanden haben muss man ja
auch nicht super schlau für sein das zu
wissen ja wir sind kurzfristig optimiert
Wesen wie müssen wir dann Strukturen
bauen damit wir nachhaltig leben und das
ist deshalb auch ein sehr interessanter
Punkt weil wir sind jetzt schon wieder
in dieser Situation dass wir sagen okay
ist so schon so schlimm ist es so
schlimm wird es der eine oder andere
wird vielleicht schon wieder sagen jetzt
höre ich das schon wieder ich bin
komplett ab genervt wir merken es auch
hier in der Vorbereitung der Sendung es
kommt auch immer wieder die Position
welche Krise welche Klimakrise wie kommt
das dass viele Fakten da sind die
Wissenschaft klare Ansagen macht und
trotzdem
abgemildert darüber gesprochen wird oder
das verleugnet wird hast Du eine Idee
kommt
ich glaube ganz großes fehlt immer noch
am Verständnis dessen was es wirklich
bedeutet also deine Frage vorhin ein
Grad 1,5 Grad mehr was ist denn das also
wenn wir reden zur Zeit die aktuelle
Erwärmung in dieser Sprache der
Klimaforschung 1,09 Grad um 1,09 Grad
waren die Jahre 2000 bis 2020 wärmer als
1850 bis 1900 wir sind nicht in der Lage
den Unterschied den
Temperaturunterschied hier in diesem
Studio von einem grad überhaupt nur zu
fühlen jetzt geh mal raus und sagt den
Leuten was soll dramat das so dramatisch
daran sein soll wenn es jetzt noch mal
ein Grad wärmer ist und wir müssen uns
aber in der gesamten Kommunikation auch
von diesen statistischen Mittelwerten
lösen wir müssen aufzeigen was bedeutet
das denn eigentlich wir müssen auf die
einzelnen Orte schauen wir müssen glaube
ich wirklich ohne den Teufel an die Wand
zu malen aber zu sagen Leute 1,09 Grad
und dann sehen wir diese Katastrophe im
Jahr 2023 nur ein Beispiel
auch vergessen 1993 war im Nordwesten
Deutschlands der letzte Sommer in dem es
kein einzigen Tag über 30 20 Grad gab
also das heißt da war der wärmste Tag
des Jahres 29 kann man noch was in
dieser Woche im September warten wir
schon fünf Tage mit mehr als 30 Grad das
ist der Unterschied und wir werden eben
ja wir werden mehr Regen wir werden aber
genauso auch verheerende dürren bekommen
bei uns in Deutschland es ist kein
Widerspruch wir werden mehr Dürren und
mehr Starkregen bekommen und deshalb wir
müssen dahin schauen dann können wir
auch etwas machen wir müssen aber
wirklich dahin schauen was davon zu
kommen unbestritten ich glaube das ist
auch wichtig und richtig ist die
Konsequenzen klar aufzuzeigen auch
gewisse widerspricht zum Beispiel Fragen
gleichzeitig trockener und feuchter
werden oder extrem Niederschläge geben
das ist aber kein Widerspruch es wird
einfach wärmer dadurch verdampft auch
sehr viel mehr Wasser dadurch kannst du
Trockenheit kommen so es ist aber
kompliziert und ganz wichtig viele
fühlen sich einfach auch machtlos auch
angesichts dieses Trommel Feuers an
Nachrichten und ich glaube das ist zum
gewissen Teil auch nachvollziehbar ist
wirklich meiner Meinung nach die
schwierigste Aufgabe bevor der die
Menschheit je stand da steckt aber auch
Optimismus drin wenn wir die gemeinsam
lösen als Kollektiv der ungefähr 8
Milliarden dann haben wir etwas
geschafft was wirklich unglaublich ist
wir haben nämlich ein Problem gelöst wo
jeder einzelne nur sehr wenig daran
ändern kann man trägt eben nur ein
milliardenstel zu den Emissionen bei
Deutschland trägt eben nur zwei Prozent
bei heißt natürlich nicht dass man sich
aus der Verantwortung stehlen kann es
macht es aber zu einem Problem wo die
Gefahr sehr hoch ist dass die Leute
einfach auf dem Zug nur mitfahren und
die Vorteile einen sacken wenn andere
das klimaschützen
und ihre eigenen Emissionen aber gar
nicht so viel an der Gesamtlage ändern
Trittbrettfahrer Problem nennt man das
ja und das ist unglaublich schwer zu
lösen und das dauert Jahrzehnte und wir
gehen das an über internationale
Organisationen und so weiter aber es ist
ein verdammtes Problem wie wir über
dieses ganze Thema sprechen also ich bin
ja jetzt auch wieder darüber gesprochen
was passiert eigentlich wie schlimm wird
es eigentlich und dann sind wir ganz oft
bei diesem Thema was müssen wir alles
jetzt deswegen lassen also was müssen
wir aufhören zu tun das müssen wir
verbieten und genau sie haben es gerade
auch gesagt es gibt Lösungen es ist
nicht so dass wir hier irgendwie vor
also es ist ein riesiger Aufgabe aber es
gibt Lösungswege die wir gehen können
und wir konzentrieren uns aber immer so
sehr darauf was wir eben alles nicht
mehr dürfen und abschaffen müssen und
beenden müssen aber wir schauen uns eben
dann nicht an wie kann es dann aussehen
dass wir diese Welt in der wir auch
leben wollen ja also wir wollen ja alle
irgendwie das ist uns gesundheitlich gut
geht und wenn nicht jeden Sommer bei 42
Grad alle Fenster zu machen und uns nur
noch in die dunkle Wohnung verziehen
sondern dass wir viel mehr darüber
sprechen müssen wie kann das dann
aussehen wie wollen wir als Gesellschaft
zusammen leben und das ist ja eigentlich
auch was schönes ist weil darin ja auch
super viel steckt wie wir unsere
Lebensräume verändern können unsere
Städte verändern können mehr grün
weniger Autos mehr als Stichwort mehr
Lösungen und auch mehr positive
Kommunikation Klimaschutz ist auch eine
Chance wenn wir auch gleich noch mal
drauf schauen Frau unheimlich würde
interessieren
jule hat es gerade angesprochen warum
ist das eigentlich so dass wir
Klimaschutz und so weiter immer mit
Verzicht in Verbindung bringen unser
Gehirn ist eben nicht nur dieser
kurzfristig denkender Apparat da oder
diese Struktur ist es keine Maschine
eine häufiges Missverständnis dass wir
es irgendwie als Computer sehen aber so
ja eine Infrastruktur da in unserem Kopf
wenn es vielleicht so uns vorstellen
weil die eben nicht nur kurzfristig
denkt sondern natürlich auch alles also
ich sag jetzt so natürlich aber ich sage
gleich warum ich natürlich sagen alles
Negative schwerer gewichtet warum weil
dieses Gehirn natürlich als erstes mal
eine Aufgabe hat uns am Leben zu halten
sprich wenn es eine negative Nachricht
verpasst dann kann das bedeuten dass es
sehr unangenehm ein bisschen zum Tode
führt und deshalb haben wir sowas das
wird in der Psychologie als Verlust aber
Version bezeichnet also sprich wir haben
immer mehr Angst davor etwas zu
verlieren als etwas zu gewinnen das kann
man sogar beziffern mittlerweile bei
Studien gezeigt haben wenn Menschen von
zehn Euro oder andere Währung dann
verlieren um einen ähnlich großen
positiven
gefühlsimpuls zu haben müssen wir 20
Euro bekommen also es ist ungefähr ein
Faktor doppeltes ja so und das heißt es
eine zusätzliche Herausforderung aber
auch das alles bekannt ja weil es ja
eben auch darum geht was für Lösungen
brauchen wir das ist alles da das Wissen
ist da also sowohl in der Psychologie
wie funktioniert unser Gehirn und wie
können wir besser damit umgehen als auch
in der Technik wie schaffen wir Dinge
wie Energiewende nachhaltige Mobilität
Wohnen Essen alles was dazu gehört zu so
leben das was aber noch fehlt ist so die
dritte Art des Wissens bzw da müssen wir
wie gesagt den Schalter noch mehr im
Kopf umlegen ist nämlich das jetzt
anzunehmen und diese Vorstellung
wirklich aktiv anzugehen und Strukturen
zu schaffen die das belohnen und nicht
bestrafen da würde ich gerne mal den
Schritt weitergehen wir haben jetzt ein
bisschen über den Status vor geredet wie
fühlen wir uns wie sieht's draußen aus
und was sind über überhaupt im Moment
bereit aufzunehmen und umzusetzen
Maßnahmen haben wir jetzt gerade schon
gehört das ist ja einiges da es gab zwei
wichtige Treffen in dieser Woche es auf
den ersten Klimagipfel in Afrika da hat
UN-Generalsekretär gut Heeres ganz
deutlich gesagt wir brauchen jetzt
Quantensprünge also er sagt nicht mehr
Mensch hier zwei dreißig zwei 45 das
sind doch so wir haben doch Zeit hat
sich dabei auch speziell Richtung G20
gewandt die sich ja auch getroffen haben
in dieser Woche und ich habe es mir
extra auch geschrieben weil ich fand es
so interessant da gab es dann zu
Formulierungen wie wir unterstützen die
Bemühungen des Handeln zu beschleunigen
ähm warum fällt es uns so schwer eine
globale Lösung zu finden warum haben wir
nicht alle
ja die Angst das zu verpassen vielleicht
eine Todes gefeiert auch zu verpassen
was ist da los ich glaube das Spielen
zwei Phänomene eine große Rolle das eine
wurde gerade schon angesprochen das
Trittbrettfahrer Problem einfach sich
als Staatengruppe zu sagen okay wir
haben jetzt dieses Ziel und ich guck mal
was die anderen machen und kann mich
erstmal ein bisschen zurücklehnen also
dass das eine große Problem und das
andere ist eben einfach dass wir ganz
viele Ziele Konflikte und verschiedene
Interessen haben die dann an einem Tisch
zusammenkommen natürlich gibt es starten
die ihren Reichtum auf ein bisschen
Energien aufgebaut haben und das gerne
in den nächsten Jahren noch weiter
machen möchten eigentlich und da spielt
dann eben dieses Phänomen ja das
Gefangenen Dilemma heißt das in der
Ökonomie das ist nicht rational ist für
diese Länder Klimaschutz zu betreiben
weil es weil sie alleine nichts
verändern können das ist ja auch das was
wir alle selber kennen so wenn ich ihn
jetzt die Bambus Zahnbürste kaufe
verändert das erstmal nichts am
Grundproblem aber eben auch wenn dieses
eine Land anfängt wirklich komplett auf
die erneuerbaren Energien zu wechseln
100 Prozent Strom aus erneuerbaren
Energien dann sind wir wahrscheinlich
nicht näher am den 1,5 Grad als vorher
weil eben alle anderen fast 200 Länder
bei von den UN-Mitgliedstaaten ist nicht
getan haben und das heißt rationales für
einzelne Länder eigentlich ja nicht
sinnvoll das zu tun das heißt wir
brauchen diese Staatengemeinschaften
deswegen ist auch total wichtig dass es
treffen wie die G20 gibt und
klimaverhandlung auch wenn es immer so
aussieht als würde da nicht so viel
passieren aber am Ende hätten wir sonst
das Pariser Klimaabkommen nicht und
würden hier nicht über 1,5 Grad sprechen
darüber oder können wir das Abhaken 1,5
Grad es wird noch aber unterm Strich
können wir es eigentlich abhaken wir
werden es nicht mehr schaffen weil wir
auch das Ruder nicht so schnell
rumkriegen und ich glaube übrigens es
würde sich sehr wohl für einzelne Länder
sehr lohnen dort als Vorreiter sich zu
positionieren weil die Länder die sich
ganz vorne positionieren und als erste
zeigen wie es geht die sind auch eine
Blaupause für andere und die setzen sich
eben auch wirtschaftlich für die
nächsten Jahrzehnte an die Welt bzw wir
reden ja auch darüber dass auch
Unternehmen die als erste es schaffen
den Weg zur CO2 Neutralität hinzulegen
die sind ja auch im international
Wettbewerben stärker aufgestellt es ist
auch eine Arbeitsplatzsicherung es ist
eine Zukunft
eine ganz große Angst bei den Menschen
und ich glaube auch bei vielen etwas an
denen wie wir es gelernt haben uns zu
verhalten daran etwas zu ändern und das
dann kommen diese Ängste ich glaube das
Problem ist dass viele dass dieser Weg
also natürlich wenn man es dann
geschafft hat hat man die Vorteile das
Problem ist der Weg dorthin weil ich
mich erstmal einem Jahr in
Wettbewerbsnachteil bin weil ich mich
für einen Produktionsweg Entscheide der
für mich teurer ist und alle anderen
können weiterhin auf jeden Fall
anstrengend also geistig anstrengend man
muss sich hinsetzen und muss sich
überwinden etwas zu tun und es wird auch
Geld kosten wir haben ein Wort zum Thema
Gewohnheiten an der Stelle weil genau
das ist so das was in meinem Kopf dann
hochploppt wenn ich dieser Diskussion an
einer Folge weil wir natürlich auch
diese gewohnheitswege wir kennen das
alle Umgangssprache mehr Mensch ist ein
Gewohnheitstier und genau das sehen wir
gerade auf globaler Ebene also auch in
allen möglichen Organisationsformen
nicht nur ich als Individuum mit der
bambürste sondern eben auch als Stadt
als Land eben auch als Zusammenschluss
und es kostet so viel Mut zu sagen so
wir machen das jetzt anders oder ich
mache das jetzt anders und da ist glaube
ich ganz wichtig jetzt lösungsorientiert
gedacht diese Kernfrage sich zu stellen
welche Organisationsform ist für ein
bestimmtes Problem oder eine bestimmte
Chance wenn man schon mal ein bisschen
lösungsorientiert verpacken wollen ist
die richtige Ebene und da sehen wir zum
Beispiel das dann vielleicht nicht immer
die beste Lösung sind sondern eher
Städte und Kommunen warum weil wir
automatisch mehr den Teller vor uns
haben nämlich die soziale Nähe weil das
Wetter wir hatten eben schon Fenster
aufmachen und und Dinge spüren oder eben
auf dem Teller wahrnehmen das nehme ich
halt direkt wahr und das ist ja ganz
häufig egal wie bei
Durchschnittstemperaturen oder
staatlichen Finanzierung und so weiter
kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen und
wenn es große Zahlen sind sowieso nicht
das kann unser hirness also müsste man
ein bisschen an sich ran holen ich finde
es auch ganz interessant auch hier die
Frage muss Deutschland in so einer Frage
eigentlich sich als Vorreiter
Positionieren der Stand sollten wir uns
da positionieren oder überhaupt mehr
also das ist ein lange gepflegtes
Vorurteil der deutschen über sich selbst
fast positives Vorurteilen nur weil wir
die ersten waren die angefangen haben
Müll zu trennen und Solaranlagen zu
fördern wir sind als absolute Mittelfeld
abgerutscht ja gerne mit ein paar
Grafiken dazu unterstützen weil wir
wollen zwar nicht zu sehr jetzt über
Zahlen und in die nicht verständliche
Details gehen aber wir müssen natürlich
über CO2 Emissionen sprechen und da
gibt's eine Entwicklung wir schauen uns
das mal an
die Kurve ist ansteigend was die
globalen Emissionen angeht und immer wir
haben gerade darüber gesprochen wir
wissen dass es der Hauptfaktor da müssen
wir ganz radikal eigentlich runtergehen
jetzt sehen wir steigt an und die
Prognosen sind aus wird auch noch in den
nächsten Jahren ansteigen da muss ich
jetzt einfach mal in die Runde fragen
sind wir eigentlich verrückt sind wir
Ihre Frau ohne warum was also danke weil
genau diese Folie zeige ich bei
Vorträgen wenn ich über das Thema
spreche und stelle dann diese Frage den
Publikum und sage sind wir eigentlich
alle irre also global gesehen wir müssen
natürlich noch mal differenzierter
gucken uns auch gleich noch mal an genau
und so weiter schauen aber global
gesehen wissen wir seit Jahrzehnten was
wir tun müssen tun aber genau das
Gegenteil weil wir jetzt mit Rückblick
auf das letzte Jahr 19 Rekordwert von
36,8 Gigatonnen das Problem entsteht ja
dann das immer wieder bei den
Durchschnittstemperaturen kann sich
irgendjemand wieder hier in der Runde
noch jetzt vielleicht an den Geräten
dieser Nation vorstellen 36,8 Gigatonnen
CO2 natürlich nicht ja so das heißt wir
müssen natürlich andere Ernährung und
das ist die Aufgabe von von gute Lieder
wie es dann so auf neudeutsch häufig
heißt oder eben auch politischen
Strukturen und gesellschaftlichen
Debatten und zu überlegen wir wissen das
doch alles rational kognitiv haben wir
das verstanden nicht das ist alle wissen
aber wir als Menschheit sozusagen ist
das wissen da und jetzt müssen wir uns
überlegen wie müssen wir das
runterbrechen damit wir endlich von
diesem irrenpfad runterkommen weil die
Definition von irre ja wäre genau er ist
genau dann brechen wir das mal noch ein
bisschen weiter herunterstand wir
schauen uns die Balken mal dazu an und
da sehen wir nämlich dass Deutschland 83
Millionen Einwohner
auf Platz
sieben liegt bei den CO2-Emissionen und
wir sehen auch gleich wieder ein sehr
beliebtes Argument ja aber am Ende sind
ja nur oder in dem Fall hier sogar
weniger als zwei Prozent
insgesamt global gesehen was Deutschland
angeht ja aber dann können wir doch eh
nichts machen finde ich immer die die
die stiftet mehr
Verwirrung als tatsächlich Aufklärung zu
leisten Indien zum Beispiel hat pro Kopf
natürlich dramatisch nie unsere
CO2-Emissionen als Deutschland oder ein
anderes Gedankenexperiment wenn sich
China in seine etwa 30 Provinzen
aufspalten würde wer dann das China
Problem auf einmal weg
die EU insgesamt mit den 27 übrigens auf
Platz drei hinter China und den USA also
wir können jetzt uns immer kleine
aufteilen das ist ja in Bayern
darum kann es also nicht gehen es geht
schon um die CO2-Emission pro Kopf das
ist schon das ist das zentrale
der Zentrale Maßstab auf jeden Fall ähm
ich glaube dass sie aber ganz froh sein
können dass die Emissionen doch von der
Hauptteil der Emission etwa zwei Drittel
auf diese ganz wenigen großen Länder
entfällt was das etwas politisch etwas
weniger kompliziert macht
es gab ja die Idee von Olaf Scholz das
klima-clubs Länder dazu zu bringen
gerade die großen Industriestaaten dazu
zu bringen
gemeinsam in CO2-Preis was extrem
wichtig wäre einzuführen über Europa
hinaus
das macht mir im Augenblick ehrlich
gesagt am meisten Sorge dass die
regelbasierte Weltordnung die noch nie
so richtig gut funktioniert hat
natürlich im Augenblick durch den Block
Konflikt China USA sehr sehr stark
gefährdet ist über Russland brauchen wir
gar nicht zu reden das wird es schwerer
machen wir brauchen eine Welt die auch
politisch zumindest gemeinsame Ziele
produktiv verabreden kann um die
globalen Emissionen zu senken
auf etwas vereinbaren dass man sagt
fossile Energien sondern abgeschafft das
sind alles immer nur wir unterstützen
weiterhin Handlung jetzt haben wir
gerade über Lösungen gesprochen Frau
sende gibt's denn die Möglichkeit zu
sagen
es gibt eine zwei Maßnahmen die
funktionieren jetzt wenn es jetzt machen
würden gibt es das denn oder ist das
wirklich zu naiv gedacht ich glaube wenn
es jetzt eine eine Lösung für alles gäbe
das wäre sehr schön aber das sind eben
die vielen kleinen Dinge die passieren
müssen ein Emissionshandel ist schon
einfach das Instrument wenn man sagen
kann da kann man einfach super viel mit
abdecken nicht nur jetzt wie in diesem
klimaklub was da vor allem den
Industriesektor abdecken soll sondern
eben alle Sektoren die wir haben die
gerade CO2 ausstoßen die Landwirtschaft
die jetzt immer noch nicht in einem
Emissionshandel gerade abgedeckt ist der
Verkehr Gebäude ja Energiewirtschaft
grundsätzlich es gibt da schon
vereinzelt eben Emissionshandel auf
EU-Ebene auf Deutsch also auf nationaler
Ebene hier in Deutschland aber eben noch
nicht dieses Modell dass wir das
irgendwie global haben und dass wir
natürlich ein großer großer Hebel wenn
man das schaffen würde aber das
scheitert natürlich daran dass gerade
viele Staaten andere Interessen haben
oder dann auch sagen da können wir nicht
mitgehen oder das ist super schwierig
das auszuhandeln aber es wäre meiner
Meinung nach das effektivste Mittel und
auf jeden Fall eigentlich was worauf man
sich mal verständigen müsste vielleicht
ganz kurz uns auch an einem Satz
runterzubringen wir müssen einfach
aufhören fossile Energieträger benutzen
also das ist sozusagen das übergeordnete
Ziel bzw das ist das beim nächsten
Weltklimagipfel im Dezember so
beschlossen wird ja das ist ja jetzt die
Frage der vorstellungskrise also wir
können ja zum Beispiel hier und heute
jetzt ohne jetzt total naiv klingen zu
wollen schon mal sagen okay was müsste
denn dafür passieren damit genau das an
einen ein Bild wird was wir uns
vorstellen können und welche Maßnahmen
brauchen wir dafür weil wenn wir direkt
wieder in diesem Modus gehen naja das
wird halt nicht passieren und die haben
die Interessen und die haben die
Interessen na ja es kann ja nur
scheitern sondern einfach mal fast so
ein bisschen naiv wie es häufig Kindern
oder so vorgeworfen wird zu fragen okay
was bräuchten wir denn dafür und es
fällt zum Hirn ziemlich schwer ich weiß
was geht ja immer in diesen aber Modus
in Deutschland ist das besonders
ausgeprägt ja und sagt dann ja aber die
und die so und aber einfach das mal
zuzulassen jetzt habe ich ja selbst aber
gesagt und zu überlegen was brauchen wir
dann dafür weil das ist das Ziel noch
mal das haben wir global vereinbart von
mittlerweile über acht Jahren und es ist
völlig klar Stichwort sind wir
eigentlich alle irre dass das passieren
muss die Frage ist einfach nur wie viel
Katastrophe und das haben wir eben auch
schon hier einmal ganz gut
zusammengefasst denke ich wie viel
Katastrophe muss noch passieren
damit in Deutschland machen willst doch
also wir sind nicht 1,5 Grad kompatibel
kompatibel ja aber wir sind zwei Grad
unter zwei Grad kompatibel also gerade
noch Paris kompatibel mit 2035 CO2
freier Stromsektor und der Stromsektor
wird immer wichtiger werden durch
E-Mobilität Wärmepumpen und so weiter
und 20 45 will Deutschland klimaneutral
sein und da passiert ja auch sehr viel
Umstellung auf Wasserstoffwirtschaft und
so weiter
also wir haben 100 Studien und ein
Regierungsplan der uns genau dahin führt
hinterher schaffen 20 30 schaffen wir
nicht nee aber das würde wirklich mit
einem
Wohlstandsverlust einhergehen der der
Bevölkerung nicht zu vermitteln ist das
finde ich den richtigen Aspekt dass wir
da noch mal hinkommen weil wir waren
gerade schon bei der Zahnbürste
unterwegs das sind ja die globalen
Zusammenhänge über die wir jetzt
sprechen und trotzdem bleiben wir am
Ende individuell mit unseren Ängsten
aber auch mit den Konsequenzen die wir
dann vielleicht leben müssen
Kassen wie ist das wir haben es erlebt
Klimaschutz ist auch in Deutschland
etwas war mal auf Platz drei auf Platz
eins in Deutschland trennt jetzt ist
gerade wieder auf Platz drei wir
verdrängen gerne wir sagen gerne aber
warum rutscht das auch beim
individuellen immer so weit weg du
könntest ja wahrscheinlich du eigentlich
könntest du gar nicht abschalten du
machst jeden Tag Wetterbericht ähm
passiert dir das auch manchmal dass du
sagst jetzt gerade gar nicht so mein
Thema eigentlich nicht also es ist
beschäftigt mich schon eigentlich rund
um die Uhr mehr oder weniger und ich
stelle mir auch ganz auf diese Frage
aber was ich beobachte ist in diesem
Jahr haben sind wir glaube ich zum
ersten Mal aber etwas erlebt was wir in
den letzten Jahren so noch nicht erlebt
haben auf einmal durch die Diskussionen
um das heizungsgesetz weil jeder auf
einmal privat betroffen und glaube ganz
viele Menschen haben auf einmal ein
Taschenrechner ein Bleistift und ein
Blatt Papier hervorgeholt und haben auch
gerechnet oh das was kostet mich das
denn jetzt wenn ich jetzt in den
nächsten Jahren in meinem Haus
die die Öl- oder Gasheizung rausbaue und
eine Wärmepumpe installiere das heißt
der hängt ja noch andere Sachen dran und
in dem Moment bekommen die Menschen
Angst viele können sich das auch erstmal
nicht leisten deshalb ist diese
Diskussion auch wie wir das
sozialabfedern wie wir das auch
finanziell schaffen können die es
genauso wichtig wir müssen an der Stelle
wirklich auch gucken dass wir die
Menschen mitnehmen ansonsten werden die
Politiker die schauen auch auf die
nächste Wahl werde ich gewählt oder wenn
ich nicht gewählt und danach wird
entschieden und wenn die Stimmung in der
Bevölkerung so ist dass
je schneller sozusagen es auch für mich
finanzielle Konsequenzen hat und etwas
kostet dann mache ich mein Kreuz eine
anderen Stelle dann ist das eine weitere
ganz große Bremse in dieser Gesellschaft
auch
zwei Sätze ich versuch's
weil das das leisten können ich glaube
das ist der Kernbegriff an der Stelle
können wir uns das leisten und viel zu
häufig oder darf eigentlich gar nicht
mehr passieren also es ist natürlich
niemand verbieten das zu sagen aber das
wäre Anfang abzuwägen können wir uns
Klimaschutz leisten weil jede Studie
jede Analyse finanzieller Natur zeigt
uns wenn wir jetzt nicht handeln wird es
nur noch teurer und ich mache vielleicht
ganz konkret glauben wir wirklich dass
ich irgendjemand in Griechenland oder
die anderen zahlreichen Bilder die wir
eben gesehen haben sich vorhin gesagt
hat ach können wir uns das jetzt leisten
wenn so und so viel Häuser Weg ist nein
natürlich nicht also die Frage ist
einfach schaffen wir dieses kurzfristig
denken hier Hirn nicht zu überlisten
sondern einfach anzunehmen und zu sagen
ah okay das ist diese Tendenz in uns
allen egal ob ich Politikerin bin ob ich
Moderatorin bin Journalistin oder Mensch
der irgendwie seine Heizung bezahlen
will oder die Heizkosten und was
brauchen wir dann für Strukturen damit
nicht noch teurer wird aber wie könnte
man das denn schaffen also man kennt
alle man kennt diese Studien das ist am
Ende des Tages
werden wir für die Katastrophen immer
mehr bezahlen viel teurer als jeder
zentime jetzt in die
co2-emissigung reinstecken warum kriegt
unser Gehirn
also ich kann gerne aber sie haben auch
Luft geholt
ist mit dem Gehirn ist total interessant
aber ich finde die die politische
Qualität ist da so eklatant wichtig dass
das Gehirn vielleicht gar nicht so im
Vordergrund steht unsere menschlichen
Schwächen also das heizungsgesetz wurde
ja gerade angesprochen wir sprechen ja
über die Welt aber letztlich sagt das
passt prototo auch sehr viel aus es gab
zwei ganz grundlegende Fehler erstens es
gab keine klare CO2 Bepreisung das
klingt erstmal abstrakt aber wenn ich
mich als heizungsberater sie haben es
gerade gesagt die Leute saßen wirklich
mit dem Bleistift ist erstmal da und
wenn ich gar nicht weiß was ich dabei
Erdgas im Jahr 2035 eintragen soll ich
gar nicht weiß wie hoch der CO2-Preis
dann ist der muss sehr hoch sein dann
lohnt sich diese vielleicht ja auch
scheinbar noch mal eine Gasheizung
einzubauen aber ist total klar das ist
das CO2 sehr sehr teuer werden wird da
keine klare Zeit zu liefern der erste
Kardinalfehler der zweite Kardinal
Fehler keine förderregeln und keine
regionale sie haben vorhin die Städte
ins Spiel gebracht die können ja nicht
alleine den dieser noch viel kleiner als
die Staaten aber da muss es ja umgesetzt
werden in den Kommunen und keine
förderregeln zu haben den Leuten nicht
zu sagen ihr bekommt die und die
Unterstützung das bekommt ihr nicht und
den Kommunen nicht zu sagen ihr braucht
die und die Regeln und dann gelten diese
Vorschriften für die Heizung das kann
man sich ja fast gar nicht ausdenken wie
schlecht gemacht das war und da kann man
auch global sehr viel draußen lernen ähm
genau das sind eben die Dinge die das
auch begleiten müssen noch ein weiterer
Punkt wäre zum Beispiel das Klimagerät
dass die Ampel auch nicht auf die Reihe
kriegt also die Rückzahlung der
Einnahmen durch den CO2-Preis das würde
ja auch soziale Fragen gleich mit
beantworten davon würden ja
ärmere überproportional profitieren was
eine pro Kopf Auszahlung wäre und die
reichen oder wohl haben den stoßen eben
mehr CO2 auszahlen also auch nicht die
politische Dimension von dem was ich auf
jeden eben erklärt habe und Herr
schwanger ehrlich gesagt ist Politik
wird gemacht in unserem Land mit einem
vierjahreszyklus in anderen Ländern wie
drei oder fünf Jahre und genau das ist
so also ich bin dankbar dass sie genau
diese konkreten Dinge jetzt ausgeführt
haben weil das ist das was ich quasi
neurobiologisch wir haben ja auch
Politiker und Politikern so einen Hirn
und denken halt an den nächsten
wahlzyklus und deshalb haben wir diese
klaren Zahlen nicht genau deshalb
brauchen wir da andere politische
Vorgaben damit diese Sicherheit im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes das ist ein
wichtiger Begriff politische Vorgaben
brauchen wir mehr Vorgaben weil
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich auch
nicht wenige Menschen die sagen ich
möchte nicht bevormundet werden ich
möchte selber entscheiden was ich
einkaufe was ich esse ist es vielleicht
ja zu viel oder brauchen wir die Wohnung
an der wichtige Punkt auf den wir gerade
eigentlich anzusprechen kommt diese
Verunsicherung die einfach in der
Bevölkerung da ist weil man nicht weiß
was mache ich jetzt eigentlich und was
ist der richtige Schritt und da braucht
es mehr Orientierung weil Menschen da
sehr viel investieren müssen das ist
auch das Ersparte ist und Solaranlage
auf dem Dach die kostet und da kann man
sich nicht noch mal eben dann noch ein
Auto und die Wärmepumpe im Keller und
zack zack aber wird es leichter wenn das
jemand für mich entscheidet du musst
jetzt eine nehmen das das wird genauso
teuer sein auf jeden Fall aber es hilft
auf jeden Fall wenn man dann schon mal
zeigt okay die und die Option die sind
nicht sinnvoll die sollte man nicht mehr
irgendwie mit in ein heizungsgesetz
Schreiben wie zum Beispiel Wasserstoff
Wasserstoff infra also Infrastruktur
wird es für die privaten Haushalte nicht
geben ist auch eher ineffizient weil
Wasserstoff einfach sehr sehr viel mehr
Strom braucht um oder Wasser um das
überhaupt herzustellen die Elektrolyse
braucht sechs Mal so viel Strom als wenn
wir eben direkt den den Strom nutzen für
eine Wärmepumpe und das heißt einfach
wir müssten wir bräuchten mehr grünen
Strom den haben wir sowieso schon mal
nicht wir haben auch nicht viel grünen
Wasserstoff später zur Verfügung den
braucht die Industrie kann man sich
irgendwann zusammenrechnen okay macht
eigentlich keinen Sinn für private
Haushalte dann schreibt man sowas nicht
mehr eingesetzt rein aber
Situationen ich glaube auch dass es
flächendeckend gar keine Rolle spielen
wird aber bei bestimmten sehr ländlichen
Blockheizkraftwerk oder ähnlichen kann
schon sein dass Wasserstoff
eine gewisse Rolle spielen wird
so eine Vorfestlegung ich finde es
schwierig weil Menschen natürlich jetzt
denken okay ich nehme eine H2 also eine
Gasheizung die später auch mit
Wasserstoff betreiben kann
aber ist das Frauen ist das etwas was
uns wirklich helfen würde wenn wir sagen
würden wir kriegen klare Vorgaben ich so
wird es gemacht du nimmst jetzt die
Bambus Zahnbürste und so nah auf und das
ist ganz wichtiger Punkt ich kann
absolut verstehen also ich tippe ja
genauso ich möchte nicht vorgeschrieben
bekommen was ich zu tun habe und deshalb
müssen wir einen Schritt zurückgehen und
verstehen wir haben immer eine
Beeinflussung also Politik ist doch
genau dafür also gesellschaftliches
Zusammenleben dafür da Rahmenstrukturen
zu schaffen und so ein bisschen
konkreter zu machen wir haben auch jetzt
eine massive Beeinflussung zum Beispiel
durch Subventionen ja wenn wir sehen
welche Subventionen z.B gerade in die
Produktion von bestimmten Lebensmitteln
und eben nicht in andere Lebensmittel
gehen dann wird mir damit ein Produkt
günstiger verkauft was vielleicht
eigentlich ein viel höheren Preis hat so
z.B bei Fleisch der Fall und genauso bei
fossilen Energieträgern der Fall also
wenn wir uns da mal wirklich glücklich
machen auch da wieder wie die CO2 Kurve
wirklich ehrlich machen und die Zahlen
ganz so nüchtern wie möglich anschauen
dann sehen wir dass wir immer Strukturen
haben gewachsen aus den bisherigen
Jahrzehnten und bestimmten finanziellen
Interessen die dahinter stecken und
jetzt ist einfach nur es klingt so
einfach es ist natürlich nicht einfach
die Frage kam mir eben auch schon aber
die die zu verstehen diese Beeinflussung
ist immer da wie wollen wir es denn
jetzt gestalten damit es besser ist
damit Klarheit da ist damit eine
instantivierung also eine Belohnung in
ein Verhalten da ist was nachhaltig also
ein bisschen länger als bis morgen
Mittag uns allen gut tut ich würde gerne
an der Stelle so weil wir auch schon
Richtung Ende kommen sind wir denn
bereit für Klimaschutz also wir haben
ich ich finde weiß nicht wie es Ihnen
geht aber ich ich erlebe schon dass
viele Menschen sagen ich möchte ich
trenne auch mein Müll ich mache doch ich
möchte sind wir bereit Karsten was ist
dein Eindruck in Deutschland auch zu
sagen wir gehen diese Schritte mit wir
lassen uns da auch von Lösungen
überzeugen ich sehe absolut viele
positive Beispiele und ganz viele
Menschen sind bereit aber ich finde
was wir gerade auch diskutieren wir
müssen die Leitplanken so ausrichten
dass wir die Menschen mitnehmen das ist
eben auch ein Gewinn ist also in all den
Gemeinden wo die Bürger der Gemeinden
mitbeteiligt sind an einem
Bürgerwindpark gibt es kein Protest
dagegen die Leute sehen das am Ende des
Jahres in ihrem Portemonnaie und auf
einmal habe ich Menschen die sagen super
wir verdienen damit Geld mein Strompreis
wird niedriger und dafür müsste es
eigentlich noch viel mehr geben also ich
würde mir z.B beim Thema Verkehr wir
wissen alle dass wir einen CO2 neutralen
Verkehr brauchen und und ein sehr
modernen Verkehrssektor ich möchte von
Hamburg nach München mit dem Zug in drei
Stunden fahren von Köln nach Berlin in
zweieinhalb Stunden und das wäre kein
rocket science das gibt es weltweit ganz
viele tolle Beispiele die das schaffen
würden und dann hätten wir keine
Verbotsdiskussion von innerdeutschen
Flügen dann würde jeder freiwillig auf
das Auto oder auf einen Flugzeug
verzichten wenn so etwas gut
funktionieren könnte und mehr in diese
Richtung und dann hätten wir ganz viele
Leute die dabei mitmachen würden sagen
genau das ist doch der Weg der Zukunft
aber jetzt haben sie die Frage
beantwortet die ist mir eben gestellt er
arbeitet sich auch ein bisschen was aber
genau dieses diese positiv in diesen
Nutzen den wir dadurch auch haben können
was wir aus unserer Leben besser machen
wird das müssen wir viel mehr betonen
und ich glaube auch eben um das ist auch
reicher die Frage der Sendungen die
globale Antwort ist am Ende die
nationale wie schaffen wir das als
Deutschland und wie können wir dann auch
andere inspirieren andere Länder die
dann eben auch sehen ah okay so habt ihr
das gemacht und so habt ihr das
geschafft und am Ende funktioniert das
so weil auf den Klimakonferenzen da
funktioniert das nicht so dass niemand
aber sagt am Tisch aber am Ende
funktioniert das damit dass die das das
Sagen ah okay ihr habt das so gemacht
mit eurem Stromnetzwerk ist es auch eine
Idee für uns und das ist eben dann das
was passieren muss
Informationen auch aus Paris die sind
gerade ganz begeistert von ihrem
Fahrradwegen zum Beispiel ist das wir
reden über Lösungen wir reden über
positive Besetzung ist das womit man
Menschen dazu bekommt zu sagen ich habe
auch Lust auf Klimaschutz ja ich glaube
wichtig ist wirklich die Botschaft es
geht hier nicht um Verarmung es geht
hier nicht auf halbem Weg zurück in
Steinzeit die
IEA hat das versucht mal auszurechnen
die Internationale Energieagentur bis
2050 und global was müssen wir
eigentlich machen und das war total
interessant nur acht Prozent der
Einsparungen sind wirklich echte
Verhaltensänderungen also echter
teilweise auch Verlust zum Beispiel dass
man den Wohnraum eben begrenzt hält wir
haben ja 10 Quadratmeter mehr als vor 20
30 Jahren kann man schon die Frage
stellen ob wir in den 90ern mit unserem
Wohnraum tierisch unglücklich waren muss
man nicht zurück aber egal zwei Drittel
sind
Technologiewechsel also zum Beispiel vom
Verbrenner aufs E-Auto das ist doch
nicht so schlimm hauptsache ich bleibe
mobil das geht doch für ganz viele
Bereiche wo wir einfach die Technologien
haben z.B auf Strom basierte
Erneuerbaren basierte Technologien und
dann gibt's noch ein Drittel von dem
sieht man gar nichts weil das in den
großen Fabriken passiert ja grüner Stahl
und sowas kriegt man gar nichts mit von
also man kann eigentlich sehr
optimistisch sein das ist alles machbar
ohne großen Wohlstand
den ich gerne zum Ende
danke ihnen erstmal für diese Runde hier
es geht weiter bei Phoenix und WDR 5 mit
dem Presseclub nachgefragt da können Sie
bei uns bleiben oder hier auch im ersten
das europamagazin beschäftigt sich
übrigens heute auch mit dem
klima-maßnahmen aus Sicht von Brüssel
aber vorab auch natürlich noch mal das
Thema das große Erdbeben in Marokko
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse danke
schön für die Impulse hier und vor allem
auch für Lösungsansätze und vielleicht
versuchen wir es einfach mal so nehme
ich Ihre Botschaft danke ihnen fürs
zuschauen
[Musik]
so und da sind wir zurück beim
Presseclub nachgefragt schon dass Sie
bei uns geblieben sind wir schauen auf
unser Thema heute Sommer der extreme wo
bleibt die globale Antwort auf die
Klimakrise und da wollen wir uns gerne
unsere ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer hören
und Hörer mit reinnehmen und wir fangen
mal an mit
Silke Müller Lehmann aus oberrixien das
ist in der Nähe von Stuttgart hallo
hallo ich bin jetzt in der Sendung wenn
wir sehen aufgeregt dass man gar keine
Frage an die Runde und zwar sehen Sie
mich auch ein bisschen eine
Mitverantwortung der Medien
an dem wie mit klimaaktivist die
umgegangen wird wir haben momentan die
Situation dass die letzte Generation
mittlerweile schon angegriffen wird
tatkräftig von einigen
provozierten Autofahrerinnen und
Autofahrern und es wird immer noch nicht
darüber gesprochen was die eigentlich
wollen sondern es wird über den Protest
noch gesprochen wir hatten ähm jetzt
eine
Pressekonferenz der letzten Generation
und auch die haben beklagt es wird nicht
über Inhalte gesprochen ich finde es
toll dass sie das jetzt heute in der
Sendung gemacht haben sondern es wird
über die Protestform gesprochen und ich
möchte wissen ob sie auch und es ist an
alle in der Runde einfach in der
Verantwortung der Medien sehen
endet die International hat zum Beispiel
beklagt dass die letzte Generation in
Präventivhaft genommen wird also die
Mitglieder und es wird über dieses
Demokratie Defizit nicht in den Medien
groß berichtet
Frau Müller ich danke Ihnen für Ihre
Frage und auch für die Beschreibung des
Problems also ich möchte dazu sagen über
diese wir haben sogar hier im Presseclub
schon über die Präventivhaft gesprochen
also man kann jetzt nicht sagen es wird
nicht darüber gesprochen aber
Medien an sich und der Umgang mit
Berichterstattung sie hatten gerade
direkt aufgezeigt ja ähm ich finde diese
Präventivhaft Geschichte ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen problematisch es gab vor
drei vier Monaten ein
bild-zeitungsartikel den ich auch sehr
problematisch fand in dem nämlich nicht
ganz korrekt quasi so gerührt wurde man
könne da auch als Notwehr Gewalt
einsetzen gegen die protestieren das
fand ich beides überhaupt nicht gut oder
finde ich beides überhaupt nicht gut ich
finde aber auch die Protestform
überhaupt nicht gut sie haben es gerade
schön gesagt ja es wird ja nur darüber
gesprochen aber nicht über die Inhalte
ja genau weil man diese Protestform
wählt also das große Problem dass ich
damit habe ist dass man wirklich
Menschen in ihrem Alltag behindert die
ganz normale Leute sind mittags um 13
Uhr in Berlin das sind sogar würde ich
sagen eher die
ärmeren Leute die einfach ihrem Job
nachgehen müssen die Dinge ausfahren die
werden aufgehalten können ihrem Alltag
nicht nachgehen
und es ging ja auch so ein bisschen in
die Richtung Berichterstattung ist das
ähm also der Vorwurf ist normalerweise
andersrum dass die Medien zu stark sich
aus einem links grün orientierten Milieu
rekrutieren in ihrem Personal es gibt
sicher Medien die da komplett dagegen
gehen ich finde jetzt unsere
Medienlandschaft eigentlich insgesamt
sehr ausgewogen sie ist auch vielfältig
nach rechts nach links
dann nehmen wir mal Ulf altauf Kramer
aus in Detmold mit dazu hallo guten Tag
zusammen ich bin sehr froh dass sie
dieses Thema gewählt haben wir haben
einen Bauernhof und Wald und wir erleben
das wie die Klimakrise durch unsere
Wälder Rast und dass sie einfach mit
einer Heftigkeit und mit einer
Schnelligkeit über uns hereinbricht wie
wir das eigentlich überhaupt nicht für
möglich gehalten hätten sie gefährdet
wirklich die Fruchtbarkeit unserer
Felder und die Zukunft der Höfe und
verursacht schon jetzt unermessliche
Schäden und es ist ganz klar es wird
keine globale Antwort auf diese
menschheitskrise geben wenn wir selber
keine Antwort geben bei den
weltklima-konferenzen wenn wir von den
anderen was fordern was wir selber nicht
ausreichend tun das kann nicht
funktionieren und deswegen können wir
uns nur an die Spitze der Unterzeichner
des Paris Vertrages dieses Völkerrecht
bürgerrechtsvertrages setzen und dann
die anderen bitten es mit zu tun oder
aufrufen diese Krise ist einfach so
existenziell wie ist das noch nie
gegeben geschrieben hat in der
Menschheitsgeschichte und wir sind dabei
unsere wunderbare Welt sehenden Auges zu
einem lebensfeindlichen Ort zu machen
und das Problem ist das Schlimmste ist
dass unsere Kinder keine Chance haben
ist zu heilen wenn wir es jetzt nicht
Schatten das Ruder herumzureißen
wahrscheinlich in diesem Jahrzehnt ist
nur noch die Chance gegeben dann können
Sie es nicht mehr heilen für entsetzlich
lange Zeiträume sind sie dann dazu
verdammt in dem verheerenden Klima zu
leben welches wegen geschaffen haben und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt haben die
Runde weil ich nehme ihre Eindrücke
sonst gerne hier mit in die Runde aber
haben sie auch eine konkrete Frage wir
müssen den Populismus der derzeit sich
breit macht in der Klimakrise in der
Klimafrage Überwinden der auch teilweise
sogar aus Teilen der jetzigen Regierung
kommt wir müssen uns zusammenschließen
als Gesellschaft und einen sachlichen
und verantwortlichen Umgang damit
hinbekommen sonst haben wir keine Chance
sie dieses Problem zu lösen und wir
müssen als Gesellschaft das Problem
jetzt auflösen indem wir
zusammenschließen die Politik muss auch
Populismus verzichten wie kann das
gelingen wie kann das gelingen da ist
auch Ihre Frage Dankeschön auch für ihre
Eindrücke und vor allem kann man
vielleicht sagen auch Frau ohne das war
jetzt in klassisches Beispiel auch dafür
er hat es auch selbst erlebt er spürt es
quasi vor der Haustür ist das auch
wieder etwas wo man sagt so entstehen
dann andere Eindrücke wollte ich gerade
sagen und das ist super weil wir jetzt
noch mal vielleicht ganz kurz oder ich
ganz kurz den Punkt mit wie reden wir
eigentlich über Klimaschutz
Klimaschutz ist eigentlich
Menschenschutz und das hat der Hörer
gerade sehr sehr schön auf den Punkt
also sehr dramatisch natürlich auch aber
eben schön im Sinne von das kann jeder
nachvollziehen das das ist fühlbar das
ist erlebbar und erlebt es eben in
seiner Umgebung und seinem seine Heimat
und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Begriff
vielleicht auch noch an der Stelle jeden
Tag jetzt und deshalb dahin zu kommen
können wir uns Klimaschutz leisten oder
ist das Klimaschutz sein das ist
Menschenschutz es geht um unsere aller
inklusive aller Menschen die jetzt hier
leben und noch ein paar Jahre vor sich
haben ein gutes Leben zu gestalten und
deshalb müssen wir glaube ich auch weg
von diesem wie gesagt nehme das gerne
als Aufhänger hier noch mal mein Mini
Plädoyer nicht vielleicht über
Klimaschutz zu reden sondern auch da
andere Bilder auch noch mal auf die
vorherige Frage zurückzukommen andere
Begriffe zu nutzen damit eben nicht
automatisch weil er eben auch den
Populismus noch am Ende angesprochen hat
in diese Lager verfallen wir müssen weg
von diesem das ist ein grünen Thema oder
ein linkes Thema oder was auch immer das
geht um alle Menschen egal welche Partei
ich wähle weil Essen und atmen müssen
wir alle
hacken darf ich würde mir sogar auch
sogar wünschen dass wir ähm die
Leitplanken auch gesetzlich es gibt
einige Länder die sind deutlich stärker
im Gesetze gegossen haben Schweden z.B
dass wir die Leitplanken gesetzlich
festmauerern und nicht noch populistisch
auch selbst in der Regierung noch
darüber diskutieren ob wir es überhaupt
machen wollen dafür müssen wir wegkommen
also das sollten wir schon ganz klar
sagen das ist der Weg und zwar mit dem
CO2 Pfad und die finde ich die
politischen Verantwortlichen können sich
dann innerhalb dieser Leitplanken die
aber stärker gegossen werden müssen als
sie es bis heute sind können sich da
drin in den politischen Wettbewerb
bewegen damit sie aber nicht noch im
Jahr 2023 über das ob überhaupt
diskutieren ich würde gerne Markus
Hofmann noch mit dazu nehmen aus
Erlangen hallo Herr Hoffmann Ihre Frage
bitte
als ich habe folgende frage ich war in
Griechenland es gab ja jetzt
mittelgriechen an das größte Feuer in
Europa es war sehr schwierig dem
überhaupt her zu werden weil massiv
Löschflugzeuge Fehlen
der Brand der war katastrophal groß und
der und danach gab es plötzlich diese
Regenfälle in der Nähe ja auch in diesem
Gebiet in der Nähe also wie gesagt der
Boden ist natürlich auch eruiert durch
die verbrennten verbrannten Bäume das
heißt er kann das Wasser immer fassen
gibt's nur ein Abgänge
der Punkt ist folgendes mich würde
interessieren also der diese Wälder die
heißt ja unglaublich viel Wasser
Feuchtigkeit was passiert bei den
Bränden wenn diese Feuchtigkeit dann in
die Atmosphäre geht kann dieses extrem
unwetterereignis in Griechenland die
Folge von diesen extrem brennenden die
vorher stattgefunden haben und gelegt
worden sind von 99 20 ist dann das
konnte man eruieren die Frage ist kann
dieses extremwetterereignis kann es von
diesen Brenten kommen danke schön für
Ihre Frage Karsten gibt es da in dem
Zusammenhang nein also wir wissen das
Brände lokal auf jeden Fall auch
Gewitter starke Regenschauer auslösen
können aufgrund der starken thermischen
Entwicklung aber hier hatten wir eine
andere Entwicklung also es gab wirklich
jetzt ein Tiefdruckgebiet oder besser
gesagt es ist kalte Luft Höhenschichten
Richtung Mittelmeer geflossen und dann
hatten wir eine sehr
spezielle Situation eine nach wie vor
sehr hohe Wassertemperatur im Mittelmeer
in der Höhe kältere Luftmassen und
dieser große Temperaturunterschied der
führt zum einen zu Entwicklung eines
Tiefdruckgebietes dass ich da dreht wir
hatten einen unglaubliche sozusagen
Verdunstungsrate aus dem viel zu warmem
Mittelmeer und dadurch wurde das Tief
stärker als es ist ohne Klimawandel
gewesen wäre weil ich hatten wir eben
mehr Feuchtigkeit in der Atmosphäre mehr
Feuchtigkeit bedeutet nicht nur mehr
Regen sondern wasserdampf ist der größte
Energieträger in der Atmosphäre das
heißt dadurch war es eben auch noch
deutlich intensiver die Gewitter wollten
wurden größer und der Regen war in der
Intensität eben auch stärker das hatte
aber mit den brennenden davor so nichts
zu tun Wolfgang Hampel aus Heidelberg
ist heute auch bei uns herzlich
Willkommen ja schönen guten Tag
Sekunde also ich rufe aus Heidelberg an
wie gesagt und wir haben ja eigentlich
das immer zu einer grünen Stadt aber wir
stellen fest dass er immer mehr Schotter
gelten hier kriegen
ob nicht da ist und ähm obwohl es ein
Gesetz gibt in Baden-Württemberg
wenn man sich an die Ämter wendet man
kriegt auch keine Hilfe die
schultergärten bleiben
nicht ändert
tja wenn da kein Bewusstsein ist frage
ich mich wie wollen wir da dann die
Ziele kommen ja danke schön Herr Hampel
für die Frage wie das ist eigentlich
gerade dieses ganz individuelle was er
da jetzt angesprochen hat auch ne das
ist dieses Mal ärgert sich das noch
quasi noch niemals der Nachbar hinkriegt
den schottergarten nicht abzuschaffen
aber spielen halt wieder soziale Normen
mit rein also diese Schotter geht nicht
ich weiß jetzt nicht genau muss jemand
aus der Runde sagen ich weiß es nicht
wann das auf einmal in
Anführungsstrichen schick wurde ja so
ein schottergarten zu machen also ich
kann mich noch daran erinnern dass ich
das nirgendwo gesehen habe und dann kam
das so langsam genau so und ähm es ist
so eine Art ich will nicht sagen das
sind soziale Normen geworden ist ein
schottergarten zu haben aber das ist
halt etwas ist worüber man sich auch ein
Stück weit ohne dass jetzt zu groß
aufhängt zu wollen identifiziert es ist
in Ordnung geworden und man gehört
vielleicht auch jetzt ne dazu wenn man
so ein Schotter Garten hat so und dann
setzt man sich da immer wieder sozialen
Nähe dann setzt man sich halt über
bestimmte Vorschriften ist ja auch
gerade der Hörer geschildert hat hinweg
weil man sagt okay ist aber wichtiger da
sind wir genau wieder bei dieser
Herausforderung was ist näher an den
Menschen dran ja und die die Verbindung
und die vorstellungskrise das ist halt
nicht da ach dieser schottergarten führt
jetzt vielleicht dazu dass andere
Lebensbereiche von mir negativ
beeinflusst werden diesen Moment oder
diese drei vier Schritte die man da
machen muss die sind halt häufig nicht
so offensichtlich da brauchen wir wieder
die Leitplanken die wir eben hatten und
natürlich auch andere soziale Normen
also welche Geschichten erzählen wir uns
von was ist ein guter Garten
wie wir dann miteinander kommunizieren
also dass wir nicht von oben herab sagen
dein schottergarten ist schlecht weil
sondern wirklich auf Augenhöhe versuchen
beim Film also viele Menschen ist das ja
auch nicht bewusst irgendwie die haben
gedacht das ist schön haben wir alle
anderen auch macht nicht so viel
arbeiten ist wahrscheinlich
zu kommunizieren wir nehmen Edgar
birkenkrüger mit rein aus Karlsruhe
hallo
ja hallo Jürgen Krüger aus Karlsruhe ich
habe eine Frage und zwar ich höre die
ganze Zeit auch von ihnen eine Runde
dass wir bereits schon in einer Breite
in deiner Klimakatastrophe und befinden
und ich habe mein Problem damit
wie kann man den Leute vermitteln in
welchem Zeitfenster und ich denke
manchmal das müsste einfach sich ein
kleines Zeitfenster sein damit wir China
die USA Indien die am massiv CO2
ausstoßen
das wird die zu Reduzierung bringen dass
das Klima überhaupt noch so besteht wie
das jetzt haben und wenn Sie schon
schildern dass wir jetzt schon in uns in
einer Katastrophe befinden
dann vermutlich natürlich auch dass das
bei den Menschen im Lande was auslöst
vielleicht sogar Ängste auslöst und es
wird der teilweise medial jeden Tag ist
es in Naturgesetz Ordnung dass man nur
noch über Katastrophen redet und ich
hätte gern gewusst
wegen Zeitrahmen brauchen wir eigentlich
damit wir das Klima
reduzieren beziehungsweise die
co2-ausstoße reduzieren können und dass
wir dann irgendwo auch sagen können okay
in dem Zeitfenster sollte dies passieren
okay alles klar danke Ihnen für die
Frage vielleicht noch mal der Hinweis
wir haben heute das Wort Klimakrise hier
benutzt also mir ist das schon wichtig
wir haben nicht von der Klimakatastrophe
gesprochen weil es ist einfach vielen
Menschen wichtig wie wir formulieren
aber Herr stand haben wir haben wir
einen Zeitfenster können wir da
irgendwas zu sagen ja da kommt ja wieder
diese Hilflosigkeit über die wir vorhin
schon gesprochen haben dieses Gefühl der
Hilflosigkeit ins Spiel also
wir haben uns schon verbessert ich
glaube das ist wichtig wir sind früher
auf 4,5 Grad klimaerhitzung zugesteuert
diese Kurve die wäre ja weiter nach oben
gegangen mit dem zunehmenden Wohlstand
der Schwellenländer der in den letzten
20 Jahren stark gestiegen ist wir haben
also immerhin geschafft das eine Kurve
die mal so verlief jetzt so verläuft ne
und wir sind jetzt nur noch auf dem Weg
zu 2,3 bis 2,7 das wäre sehr sehr sehr
schlecht das hätte enorme Konsequenzen
für ernten für
Wetterkatastrophen und so weiter und so
fort und wir müssen auf unter zwei Grad
kommen so Herr Merz zum Beispiel hat
gesagt ja also er hat suggeriert von der
CDU der Parteivorsitzende wir haben
jetzt so ein bisschen Pause machen zehn
Jahre Pause oder so das wäre falsch wir
müssen wirklich kontinuierlich
weiterarbeiten also die Zeit drängt aber
es gibt nicht einen Tag X finde ich
schlecht übrigens auch von letzte
Generation dass das suggeriert wird an
dem dann alles verloren ist weil dieser
Tag wird kommen und dann wird es sich
immer noch lohnen ganz viel zu tun sagen
wir mal 20 25 oder 2028 ähm und mit
dieser ewigen Weltuntergangs
Rhetorik löst man diese dieses ohnmachts
Gefühl
genau es gibt ja schon konkrete Daten
also Jahreszahlen die eben auch vom
Weltklimarat immer wieder kommuniziert
werden dass wir eben bis 2025 den Peak
bei den weltweiten Emissionen erreicht
haben können wir uns wieder auf diesem
Graph anschauen das ist nicht mehr lang
und bis 2030 eben auch die Emissionen um
ja mehr als 40 Prozent reduzieren wollen
im Gegensatz zu den Emissionen die wir
2019 hatten also das sind schon zahlen
und das sind viele Wissenschaftlerinnen
die diese Berichte schreiben die
jahrelang zugeforscht haben und das sind
Zahlen an den wir uns orientieren
sollten die auch glaube ich den Staaten
mehr als bekannt sein sollten denn die
müssen diesen Bericht immer wieder
verabschieden und ähm ja das ist das was
uns eigentlich wir uns als Ziel setzen
sollten okay wir haben eine kleine
Vorgabe jetzt noch zum Ende das war der
Presseclub nachgefragt danke Ihnen für
Ihre Meinung und Fragen und danke auch
noch mal an die Runde für das brandworte
einen schönen Sonntag den darf man ruhig
genießen
stürmische